channing one of my biggest
disappointments of the last few years is
that the 21 jump street men in black
crossover did not happen oh reach into
the car and we're right there with you
preaching to the choir i i still i still
think it can work i i really do and if
and if sony would ever really like
i think you know do the hard work and
figure out the producer sort of uh like
problems and you know that are inherent
with that film i think we can still do
it but uh you know right now right now
it's it's still i don't know why i don't
know why they're just not motivated to
do it it's a big overhead on that movie
so but it's by far and away the best
third sequel to any franchise that i've
ever read in my entire life funniest
script
or none of these scripts are none i
would not say that if if i didn't really
really believe it because i don't like
being wrong yeah uh like specifically
about that i act i i have so many other
questions but i think what i think the
hold up is probably that all the people
in men in black have to have their
contracts renegotiated for the producing
deals to make this all happen am i wrong
on this or is it is it one of these
no there's spielberg uh
neil moritz and uh god who's the who's
the other walter walter walter parks and
like they're big two big franchises yeah
they have giant uh producers you know on
that and then once everybody's kind of
like not willing to come off their feet
you you end up having a producer fee
that's essentially maybe more than the
actual budget of the movie so it's uh
it's healthy
you